orange c'est 30 millions de clients le
deuxième opérateur de téléphonie mobile
européen appartient désormais à france
télécom qui va introduire une partie de
son capital en bourse étant donné la
morosité actuelle des marchés le prix
fixé sera attractif lionel que tu saleh
à greg la stratégie de france télécom
est très clair le monde doit parler
orange france télécom y tient et met les
moyens
fin mai 2000 il rachète l'opérateur
britannique de téléphonie mobile sans
dette de quelque 40 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui
france télécom doit rentrer dans ses
fonds mais en bourse un gros quartiers
d'orange à londres un petit quartier à
paris 13 % du capital d'orange est à la
disposition du public et les
institutionnels en france près de
l'action entre 11 et demi et 13 euros et
demi par action un prix revu à la baisse
les marchés des nouvelles technologies
sont moroses mais chez france télécom on
se veut positif nous mettons ça au prix
du marché d'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
mieux pour ceux qui vont investir parce
que ils vont investir un moment où le
marché voit la bulle télécom comme on a
pu l'appeler s'être complètement
dégonflé donc ils n'ont plus beaucoup de
risques de voir il ya poursuite de cette
baisse de se produire non il vaut mieux
mettre en bourse quand le marché paraît
solide quand il paraît excessif en
réalité france télécom a trop besoin
d'argent pour attendre des jours
meilleurs
mais s'il en perd aujourd'hui au final
l'opérateur français risquent de sortir
gagnant fallait relever ce défi
sinon de rester un acteur de deuxième
angle désormais français les com est le
deuxième opérateur de téléphonie mobile
en europe 3e mondiale 30 millions de
clients et l'année prochaine
orange remplacera définitivement
itinéris aulas et mobicarte